so there was this period of sobriety
after that um and johnny was very
committed to being clean and sober and
i thought
we had finally done it
we finally did it we were through it and
we were never going back meaning it was
he was gonna be clean and sober for good
this time and we had a wonderful period
of
you know we fell back in love or
deeper in love than we were before it
seemed if things were so good
we were talking about a future again we
were talking about having kids
i mean when johnny wasn't using it was
so peaceful we had such a nut we had a
good time together we went back to
australia like that in that state
and had
a few months we even had my parents come
and visit us in australia and we were
talking about babies and about buying a
farm and you know about looking for
homes in california and we were in a
really
beautiful peaceful period it was
wonderful
it was wonderful
now how did you did you stay at the same
place that you did the earlier time
in australia we went back to a very
remodeled
version of that home i mean remodeled
very cleaned up version of that home
uh same walls same structure but looked
a bit different as you can imagine
how did you feel going back to that home
given what had happened in march early
march
you know the
the home
the home isn't the problem
you know you're
if you're living
in domestic violence you don't just not
go home you know you don't
just not go into the kitchen just
because you were slapped in that kitchen
people living in domestic violence live
in their homes
it it's that's almost
you know the home isn't the problem
that's the normal part of your home and
for me
you know johnny was my home
where we were a couple was my home um
and that home was often really violent
but it wasn't the structure itself it
was johnny
and when we went back to australia that
home johnny
was in a
completely different you know he had
done a complete
180 clean sober present
calm
we were peaceful i mean
any of the the gripes and the problems
that he
seemed to have about me
um went away when he was sober
and so we had a really
we we managed to go back to that same
house
but in a very different way it felt very
different how do you remember the first
act of violence
well you never forget it that's how i
remember it it
changes your life forever you never
forget the first time someone hits you
like that
i just had the date wrong
okay
and
how did how is it that you think you got
the date wrong
objection calls for speculation
overruled
um
i'm embarrassed to say i think i would
have liked to have believed that the
period of time
in which i had to fall in love with
johnny in which we fell in love and he
was sober
and he wasn't violent to me lasted for a
lot longer than it did
i think i would have liked to have
believed that
i
i wasn't hit so early in the
relationship and still stayed he was
also sober for a period in 2012 which
was a peaceful time for us
in which we fell in love so i
had kind of
allowed myself i guess
to forget
that the beginning of that period 2012
before he got sober was
was really violent and chaotic as well
i i'm embarrassed to say that what did
you do to be able to prepare that
account in that full accounting
well i had the benefit of my therapist
objection hearsay so
your honor
she's not saying what the therapist said
i'm just yeah i'll overrule the
objective thank you go ahead
i looked at my therapist notes at the
benefit of those notes which we had
received in february
as well as i reviewed calendars photos
text messages
my journals my diaries
of which there were many
i put all of those together it took a
lot of time
to be able to you know adequately
refresh my recollection and fill in the
details over the
course of the five years we were
together
and what did you do when you put that
all together
i um
i kind of
filled in uh
and collected all of these various
pieces of information
um and gave a fuller account as best i
could uh for each uh incidence of
violence that i had record of um i think
it was called an interrogatory
in this case in this case all right
excuse did you sign that under oath i
did okay and it was provided to counsel
for mr deb it was okay uh and was it a
pretty lengthy document
it was far too long
and
how is it that you didn't just remember
all of those events like this
that's
that's not how
your memory or my memory works you know
we were together for five years almost
four and a half
and
it was a very
violent chaotic
at times very loving
emotional
uh
relationship so as
as anyone can imagine there was a lot
going on and
unfortunately the violence became
almost normal
especially towards the end it was just
it's it's hard to even it's hard to say
that now but the violence was
almost normal and
you know your brain does with trauma
what it does
puts it away best you can
i see somebody who's changing almost
into different versions
of a person that i recognize for a week
for all night
and then he slips away
and he disappears
and then i get a different version of
him you get the insecure scared version
of him
that lashes out
in a different medium every time
so if it's
adderall junkie johnny
then he's abusive and he's bullying he's
a timer he's mean he's reactionary and
he's incendiary and anything i don't say
is cause
for violence or anger if i speak to him
honestly he's love me from the heart i'm
yelling at him
if i argue back with him the number
pieces
if i don't say anything then i am
dismissive or absent or it's found
if i
engage with him
i'm part of the problem
no matter what i do
because if i look at him the wrong way
he's a problem
if i say the wrong thing god knows what
it is
i'm the problem i'm the problem i'm
doing
that's the guy who's on a bunch of speed
what did you mean
when you were saying that to mr depp
that
no matter
my perception was that no matter what i
did
no matter
what i did to de-escalate walk away from
him to confront him to try to
nothing i did made a difference
nothing i did changed his rage at me
nothing i did changed the violence
towards me nothing i did calmed him down
and i was constantly doing a juggling
act of what kind of version of johnny i
was dealing with
there were different versions of him and
they were drastically different from one
another and even more so than them being
different from one another
they didn't even sometimes remember
what the other version did or said
they acted almost like independent
versions of this person depending on
what combination of drugs and alcohol he
was on
could you please describe
for the jury what this picture is
that is a picture of me
a
few months i believe this is april of
2015 so it's a few months after
the march incident that happened in
australia
early yeah early march in which
johnny held me down on the countertops
and my arms were cut on the glass um
and in that
attack and if we could draw attention to
your arm there
are those scars
what are those please describe for the
jury what those are
those are scars that i obtained while
johnny was um strangling me and
assaulting me on the countertop in
australia okay
michelle can you bring up defendants
exhibit 423 please
and does this accurately portray the
scene
shown
yes that's uh hold on a second i'm going
to move the admission of defendants 423
please
no objection 423 in evidence
thank you may we publish
all right and please describe to the
jury what this shows
it is a picture of me on a red carpet
you can see my scars
even though i have makeup on them
they're a bit harder to cover
because they're rather fresh
i was considering working on a tv series
that had james franco in it i was asked
if i would meet with the
people who are making the show objection
hearsay it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter overrule thank you
and um so i was considering taking that
job
and it
there was a possibility it would require
brief nudity um which i knew i would
have to negotiate down but uh obviously
that was a problem for johnny didn't
want me to do that didn't want me to
work
and um
and frankly i needed to
and
there was another
film i had coming out that i had
previously shot it's called london
fields
it was a source of a lot of fighting
between us because of the sexuality in
the role
uh it was a constant negotiation between
myself and the filmmakers they made a
film
and johnny heard told me that he had
heard
about it was unhappy with some of what
he had heard he was unhappy with me
having
done a sex scene in it that he claimed i
didn't tell him about
i did not actually film the scene he was
speaking of um he demanded that we watch
the
a screener of it which is a like a
a version of the film before it's
released we got one sent to where we
were at the time johnny chateau in
france it's in a remote part of france
and once again we're in this remote
place and
we're screening this film that i
appeared in and there was a scene a sex
scene in that movie
uh that started
before
um
johnny freaked out
because it it looked like me
it they had used a body double
unbeknownst to me without my permission
they used a body double to do a sex
scene
so i have an incredibly jealous man who
already
is upset with me for breaking the rule
that i had a sex scene on top of that
i'm telling him it wasn't me i didn't
shoot that scene
and you can imagine
um
how upset he was it was um irate and was
calling me a liar [ __ ] among other
things and we had this
that combined with the fact that i had
even entertained doing this job that
involved james franco
was a
a pressure cooker
um
i called it a week of hell later
i objection hearsay
overall
johnny at one point
slapped me in the face in our bedroom
in the chateau that we were staying in
at another moment he uh punched me
across the jaw
uh at one point um
he kind of either pushed or or through
it's hard to describe to you which of
those two it is because
i i can't tell you i just know i went
flying into this old church furniture
uh i later thought i had a concussion
uh it was the first time i thought i i
had sustained a concussion
you